so as predicted the media and others are
saying that our aunt of a footage has
been doctor we've taken them out of
context that none of it really happened
and we just made the whole thing up well
we are here to give you the full raw
footage from the day of the Ben Shapiro
event in Utah a question to you do you
think when you watch this this is
something we notice looking through we
have to edit for time of course but when
you watch the whole totality of the
video everything in context does it make
it worse I would argue that it does
leave your thoughts below in the
comments Stephen you ready to do this
yeah let's roll so dude as you as you're
walking up to them this is me as I'm
walking you all right well right away
there's no cuts in this right no cuts at
all okay so sometimes the footage could
be a little bit crampy camera so it's
jumpy everyone is yeah figures okay
socially were they all late they were
pretty much all late were they talking
are they start my show not coming in on
time the time all that they come in is
late
so what we were worried about the friend
maybe he got stabbed by an axe pick
[Music]
is that it turns out that is a
transgender person I think is a tree
that's worse than a day before that's
from the same house reading before this
is which of manga [ __ ] up there how
many yeah I'll put them with flag free
speech rally there's some free speech
protest they said yeah how many of you
have coming
it count me on one hand this is when I
started think it's getting really sad
yeah thinking more came though I
remember was sad because for those who
don't know me and Darren are up over
coming right is the shot race right
across there we rented a van it just
skimmed past us so that's what we're
shooting from and then we had to move
because we were in a parking spot so we
were watching from far away we couldn't
so that's that if you remember that's
Jenna right there that's honeybee dance
honey that's one who ended up being
arrested for the Taser which right yep
yep she was only arrested later than IEG
she's want to talk about her friends not
showing up so far isn't she also
unemployed also unemployed happily she
talks about in a second okay I can't
hear Jason
Esther know what my code name is Jason
that's right sue I didn't that's my real
name
yeah that's who we are well I saw the
team getting operated yeah once I using
code names honeybee naraz across or my
adjacent may not be my real name by the
way important
no one knew her code name was honeybee
including those investigating for this
footage that's exactly
[Music]
they say it's not our coup until you
have stupid Cody who was the other other
groups coming I blacklivesmatter of
groups coming or who else is going to be
here
yeah
wasthat Socialist Party to be here but
they're not gonna fight at all so this
guy just said he was I haven't seen this
before he said they're going to be the
ones arrested and he's saying they won't
fight there pass to this yeah the leader
what wills intending yeah we'll uh
that's the separating mark right off the
bat this is a
listen to this
everyone knows is so you're talking
about getting people miss the feeling
security to college push back and
probably give before ok so they clean
that afraid of manga people right so
proactive
not like the only thing I didn't I just
couldn't find
I got one and then we got a we got a
buddy who's very clever kids
oh well trauma kids and when I went to
find it mental health gun control [ __ ]
with a gun training of the gun at this
moment I'm still trying to determine wow
wow wouldn't he just list his guns yep I
like
order between just a regular right
that's not legal anywhere No
this is for defensive measures or that's
just kiss they were cut work they may be
caring I don't have anything this is all
within the first what are we three
minutes in they had three four minutes
in there's a Taser if she used you can
see in her bill write something I
you can fight pokers like if you go down
to like that military service or even
suppose yeah
like a bar yeah a big-ass knife combat
knife it's six blade side inches or so
it's just you strap it on your leg
this was like Chinese you have to really
stabbing them yeah yeah
good lord yeah chaired that the context
makes it so much work context makes this
worse I was so on the move I don't think
I've ever sat down to watch all of this
completely I know you you and Aaron down
in turn did they gonna taser they hate
everything you know it's all about anger
and hate yeah all you've heard them talk
about his weapons anger and hate their
Robles at a party
what a horrible roommate honoring
contracts [ __ ] we're volga weird we'll
go now we have to swear friends showing
up gosh this isn't stuff that would have
been newsworthy but it just makes you
see the face of aunt for so much more oh
yeah there's awful
[Music]
beautiful campus though beautiful
is that will that's well coming back
he's a tiny man haha he's like he's
learning how to be nonchalant from
cartoon from cartoons
Imogene snores like this so yeah there's
the the screwdriver the Andy okay nice
big so she already gave you a knife and
then he also gave me a screwdriver yeah
she gave me a knife then she doubles up
with the ice pick
that was an ice pick ice pick yeah oh it
said screwdriver I think oh definitely a
nice big and keep it thanks buddy he's
just a good friend well now were you
texting us at this point or no no I was
afraid to like even be on my phone
because I thought they would see that I
was texting somebody what what are they
talking about now I can't hear them
I'm not sure
there you guys are out there in the car
circling still that might be our van I
think it was we rented a is that every
time minivan with the Black Rose I love
you
will is so bright hey it's that guy with
the black rose tattoo on his neck
because he caught me he's really violent
we like him somebody just said so he
didn't talk about me and finally buddy
asked if he's coming it's like Kirk Kirk
yes well as the worst of disguising
anybody he doesn't just out himself yeah
everybody everybody guy with the tattoo
on his neck
so again by the way for people watching
here's a comment oh good
oh here's it this is Jenna defending
unemployment saying it's a great way to
be on time to everything you do oh she's
out now
yeah she said it's just
[Music]
oh did your camera cut out there a cake
on for a second yeah okay yeah Jason
good to meet you
watch someone's gonna say you edit it
out with stuff where they said just
kidding yeah exactly
Jason anyone's work with hidden cameras
your nose kind of what our plan is at
first yep
I want to see people in the comment
section does this make it do you think
it was taken out of context
just so happy to be there let's stab
some people it's occupy 10 those are the
good old days back when the media was
still able to cover up our violent
trails the Occupy Wall Street and I love
these guys in the video they're like oh
God
great we didn't make the cut for the
regular thing we're clear our faces
aren't on public watches get a privacy
violation complaint here yeah exactly
look at the boobs that's the training
that's clearly a man yeah
not her not a honey bee honey be more
like bitter be sorry
I'm just tired so this is where we're
just waiting to see if more people show
up still we're just waiting for the the
actions
they're also better two copies right
by the way it's funny people soon like
Republicans up there
I saw someone was that you guys
fantastic they they went there up and
down like the whole campus that's their
resume I'm really good at chalk and
stabbing people delicate right wing
snowflakes they can't have no I love how
they call the left wing snowflakes and
then like whine about shotgun yeah you
know John IV snowflakes or thugs we
can't actually thugs or cowards and you
guys are quintessential cops look at
this amor this is the movement losers
assemble take use from you so you don't
need to rally sure yeah that's what it's
been for the last eight years
exactly I think dummy the one who said
Ange bench bears the most dangerous man
in the world by the way that's her also
filed a privacy violation
I'm gonna go grab a belfie I know it's
part of this you know not a belt it was
a belt don't lose campus if you enjoyed
this clip and enjoyed the behind the
scenes of these undercover videos week
to do mug Club is the only thing that
makes that happen you can join a ladder
with Crowder comm / Mudd Club if you
want to see more videos like this
exposing things the media refuses to
cover join click Subscribe we can use
all to helping get lot of credit calm /
Mudd Club